for those who don't know me my name is
John foltz I'm the director of the user
interface group at Wolfram research
under under my purview is most notably
the mathematica front end all things
related to the mathematica front end but
also the I do mobile apps and both you
know including the wolfram alpha stuff
that we shipped and so I'm not going to
talk about those today but that's if you
have any questions that's the kind of
stuff that you can bring to me so so I'm
going to talk about a little bit about
where we've been with front-end over the
last year and a little bit about the
teasing a few things about where we're
going and one of the nice things about
some of the teasers is we've kind of
kicked up our ability to ship new
versions of the product and so unlike
you know for the long-timers around here
where we used to tease things and then
maybe like two years later you might see
them so the stuff that I'm teasing here
is by and large stuff that I would
expect to see if not by the end of the
year then very early next year so let me
talk a little bit about just by way of
explanation for those who've been here
before you know that I often give an
hour-long keynote I'm not doing that
this year and part of the reason I'm not
doing that this year is because this
year has been kind of a year of
infrastructure for us and the that
infrastructure hasn't quite hasn't quite
fully matured yet but we put a lot of
work into it so I decided to kick the
football forward one more years but let
me talk a little bit about some of the
things that we're doing just because
some of these things are things that a
lot of people have questions about and
so so I want to give you some confidence
that these are things that you know we
definitely care a lot about here so the
the big projects we've been working on
modernizing the unicode support and and
modernizing the drawing support under
windows actually the unicode support we
are just about ready to ship but the
drawing support is a little ways away
yet the the 64-bit coco port for
macintosh this is something people have
been asking about for a long time and
yes we're we're well aware that this
situation can be better on that front
and and it's in progress but it you know
it's a bigger project than well even
than we anticipated the that's a
consequence of having a source code base
it's been around for 20 years so so
we're also working on updating our
opengl and direct3d implementations a
lot of our rendering right now
pre-exists the sea change that hit
OpenGL and and direct3d when they moved
away from kind of yo regular procedural
sorts of you know drawing 2-2 running
programs on the card and we you know I
mean we do some shader stuff and that
sort of thing but but we've been limited
in what we've been capable of doing
because of the underlying infrastructure
and so that's another thing that we're
working on and as well as that a pesky
mobile operating system that people keep
asking about and yes I know there are
two mobile operating systems we're
looking at both of them but I'm only
willing to put one bullet point on here
so if you have questions about the other
one feel free to ask I may or may not
answer okay so let's let's talk a little
bit about what we are doing though and
this is the danger of giving a talk
after Steven is that he steals your
material liberally but let me go into a
little more detail about this so code
captions the idea here is that is that
almost all programming languages there
are a few exceptions but really
almost all programming languages and
certainly all programming languages with
any real traction around the globe
require if not English at least the
ability to memorize stuff that means
nothing to you but it means a lot to the
english-speaking world and the Wolfram
language is really no exception here and
in fact in the case the Wolfram language
is actually kind of a bigger deal
because because we don't have you know
20 or 30 or 50 keywords we have six
thousand or more I don't know did it
seven thousand yet it's it's getting up
there in any case and and we think a lot
about names you know names are not
slapdash you know names are you know
fundamentally you know the name and the
design of the function go together so
it's something we think a lot about and
and we realize there's an opportunity
for for branching out especially in the
educational market the that you know
there have been initiatives around the
globe to teach kids computer science
teach kids you know how to code and and
that's great for english-speaking kids
or kids even who might speak english as
a second or third language but it's
difficult for kids who haven't had that
sort of exposure so so that's the idea
here is to try to make something that
you know it's it's not a translation of
the language you're not you know typing
in stuff in your own language but at the
very least you know these things which
may be reformed to you you know you get
an idea in the same way that an English
speaker gets an idea so that's why
you'll never see code captions in
English because the language itself is
that is the English version so the we
have several languages and so here is is
Japanese and then this is a better
example of something that I want to show
in terms of I mean some languages are
very very verbose
I pick German because I it may very well
be the most for post language around and
that produces something of a challenge
when you're trying to do this sort of
thing when I was thinking about this I
was thinking about music choral music
and you know in choral music you you end
up you know you as a musician following
notes end up having these really widely
spaced bars so that all the words can
fit in underneath and line up and we
want to line up in the same way that
choral music does but we don't want to
affect the way that the the language is
actually typed and displayed other than
to have these captions in place and so
the solution that we came up with was
something where we show just as much of
the of the caption as we can here you
can see the in the geometric
transformation case is cutting off the
caption for graphics to the left but
then you know if if what you're doing is
you're reading code and a lot of times
when you'll be looking at this you know
that's where you'll start you start by
reading code you know looking at
examples other people have done and
modifying them and so and all you have
to do is mouse over and and these things
will pop out over the others and
actually the geometric transformation
when I guess was the better example
because it pops over the next the next
two subsequent ones so so that's it's an
idea that we had in terms of you know
you know jumping into the fray of in
terms of teaching kids to code and
initiatives that we're definitely
supportive of and you know if that's
something you're interested in you kind
of have you know an interest in this or
more ideas on this front love to hear
them so code captions are easy to turn
off or change language they're also on
the help system you know our help system
is riddled with examples all the
examples have code captions and in the
code captions are in the cloud front end
as well they're also in the web docs and
I think we're still working on the
JavaScript for the web docs to kind of
you know
improve that experience but I believe
it's already there at least for some
languages in the web docks and as Steven
said earlier it's you know it's it's a
nice sort of thing to do because it
actually turns out not to be that
expensive i think on my previous slide
all right yeah i listed here the
languages which we have so far these
language it wasn't that difficult for us
to to do these languages you know took
you know a couple weeks per language
basically you know one really
knowledgeable person so so other things
that we did we're continuing to work on
what we internally call our code assist
initiative the idea of code assist being
kind of twofold one is to to make it
easier to you know to quickly and
accurately type your code into the front
end and the second to be to be you know
in some cases to prompt where maybe the
code you know maybe you're not really
sure what can be done or you have some
idea of what can be done in that case to
try to get you you know to teach you
about the language you know teach you
alternate input forms or alternate
functions that you might be using or
such so so it's a lot of boring work
that's that's not too sexy but but you
know it certainly does make a big
difference you know when you're doing
something like you know say interpreter
of and sorry that came out a little
smaller I forgot to set the
magnification on that but but being able
to see just for those can't read you
know it starts with number which is the
most obvious one at the top and then
from there we can see interpreter of
nuclear explosion
that's a new one for me didn't know that
and nuclear reactor and nuclear test
site so so the you know a lot of this is
it's about systematically going through
the language and finding places where we
can figure out sensible completions and
do them and you know especially this you
know where they're these strings
selectors for you know something like
city data we can put in say my my
current hometown of st. Louis and city
data is you know being a backup function
it gets a little finicky about how you
type in things so you know we're sloppy
about it you know we say well if you
typed in a string you know it's not
valid with just a string but we figure
it out and and and we'll complete
whatever's there so and and then oops
and then and then we have one of the
things which is beginning to happen in
the language and I'm sure is going to
happen more and more is you're going to
see functions which take associations
where the string keys are that were the
keys in the Association are strings that
are basically you know value selectors
that are that are you know meaningful to
the specific function which your which
you're typing into and so send mail is
such a function where you know if you
want to it you know send mails about
sending mail and they're a lot there's a
lot of metadata related to mail and if
we just put all that in as I mean we do
have the simple cases is like the one or
two argument form or something like that
but if we added all that it be options
and options and options and and so we
set up an association input form instead
where you can then and then it figures
out that that you know that I might be
referring to subject or to server or to
server authentication all valid fields
for the Association going into the SML
yeah going into the Seminole Association
they're so so simple but you know we're
trying to make the experiences you're
especially you know with a language that
has you know six or seven or eight is it
eight thousand yet symbols so and and
one of the things which is an obvious
thing to want to do is is you want to be
able to add your own completions as well
you know if you're designing your own
code of course you want to add your own
completions and we've been doing that a
little bit of this in-house something
that didn't get the design for this
together for for the 10 3 release it
came out but I think you can expect to
see this in the next release though the
so it might look a little different from
this but the ability to basically for
any function that you want and what i'm
doing here is i'm defining a function
that takes a first argument which is a
file and so then it invoked filename
completion and a second argument which
takes a specific list of strings in this
case the list of strings which dollar
export formats evaluates to but it could
be any less of strings that you want we
can support directories we can support
colors as well and so so then I mean you
know if I type in this right now and and
I do this I get no completion but now if
I register things here and now i start
typing and now it's going to figure out
aha this first argument is indeed is
indeed a filename and so it can complete
write off my file system and then the
second argument is going to there we go
our BMP format and so you know this is
the sort of thing which one of the one
of the pet projects I've been doing for
the last year I've been building a
actually something an on front-end
related but I've been you know really
kind of hitting the front end hitting
the system is
an environment for you know real
production level stuff you want to ship
and and this was one of the first things
we realized is you know we have to get
the completions in there so okay and
then Stephen talked a little bit about
this the text grid it's attorney it
turned out not to be that difficult to
implement and it was just a you know it
was just an idea at some point where you
know somebody sent some some excel
spreadsheet around and Steven said well
why aren't we eating our own dog food
okay he actually said something a little
different maybe a little louder but but
in any case so we ended up coming up
with this idea for text grid which bills
aren't a lot of our current technology i
mean we could have you know this is a
thing that you could have built before
but it wasn't kind of quite so easy to
use so something which you know instead
of producing expressions ends up you
know just taking strings and having them
appear as text and being able to you
know being able to when i edit it to do
the right thing with you know tabbing
around but everything still remains is
text and and so
I'm glad you appreciate it in a case so
a test grade is kind of a weird little
thing because you might you know use it
for output but you might use it for
output that you really want to be added
in as well but yeah so and since I
didn't have a super long list of
functionality I did want to talk a
little bit about some of the things
which are in the pipeline things which I
could actually demo and like I said I
mean you know given that I can demo them
you know these are not too far from
heading up heading out the door so so
this is something that's this actually
in our nightly builds right now which is
real-time spell checking yes I know
other people have had it for years and
years but now we have it too so so yes
the the in fact we were close to being
able to do this for 10 3 but just needed
to polish off a few things but but yes
including you know mouse overs being
able you know to automatically just fix
things in place very simple very simple
if you actually click on ok I did say
there was a reason we weren't shipping
there we go ok and and not just not just
English we are also supporting
supporting some other languages too and
showing Spanish here we also have
Portuguese and
and korean because those are the easy
dictionaries define if you care about a
language help us define a dictionary
that we can redistribute and we'll talk
to you so but we were we are working to
to source more dictionaries and maybe by
the time the next release comes out
we'll actually have more okay the
another thing we're doing some controls
work and one of the kind of embarrassing
sorts of things which we've been missing
for a long time is combo boxes in fact I
think we've written at least three
versions in the house of things which
kind of act like a combo box but aren't
really a combo box and so now we're
doing the real thing it will be very
straightforward it's just really a combo
box just an input field with a menu list
so you know I have this here which
generates this you know which I can type
into but then I can also choose options
and so that's for those who don't know
what combo box means that means it's
kind of the combo of an input field and
a pop-up but but the more interesting
thing and I really had wanted to demo
this and we just could not quite scrape
it together for the demo but but I
nonetheless I think we will be shipping
this in the not-too-distant future is is
also supporting a fully user specifiable
user specifiable completion interface
for input fields so being able to define
your own completions which might be
dynamic as users type for example and
you see this sort of thing in I think
the most common cases probably web
browser URL bars and and so that's a
tool that we want to be able to use for
building are all interfaces and we want
to be able to provide to you as well so
something else we're had once again this
is a small thing but it's one of one of
life's annoyances which I was no longer
willing to put up with the and for this
I'm going to have to
on maximize here just a bit so it gets
some of this other stuff out of the way
so the the I work with products under
version control as I'm sure most of you
do too and it's would be really
convenient to actually be able to in
fact we just switch to get about a year
ago and it would be really convenient to
have updates from version control or
from whatever automatically reflecting
in open notebooks and not having the
notebooks fighting for access to those
files and so this is something which so
here is an example here of a notebook
which is on a given branch and and what
I'm i'm only doing wolf and language
code here just so that I didn't have to
bail out to a shell but but all this is
doing is replacing the file behind the
scenes with the version of file from
another branch and when I do that you're
going to see that it reopens with the
changes that I have on the other branch
so like I said one of one of life's
annoyances finally resolved and and this
is another one so Steven talked about
echo this morning and I and won't you
know of course how do people debug
problems in wolf and language code
frustratingly a lot of times that's with
print statements we do have debuggers
but they're you know they're not
necessarily so easy to use sometimes and
especially for people who don't have
experience you know working with
debuggers it can be very daunting and
also you know frankly debuggers tend to
work better when you're dealing with
lines of code as opposed to stack frames
where you might have you know ten stack
frames in a single line of code I mean
that's a problem that we're still
working on but but here's a you know the
debugger that we have actually the the
the most significant use case which was
really useful was message break points
so we thought well you know why do we
have to find we have to do the message
break points in order to see what's
actually happening when a message is
issued why not why not just produce and
this is a prototype so it's actually
producing two messages that's not the
final design but you see so this is the
copy of the message as it was but now we
have this new thing which when we click
will give us a time sorry once again
should adjust the magnification on this
but gives us for those who can't see
there's a stack trace there at the
bottom this fails this function fails
because it's looking for f of 0 equals 1
but I called it with F of 5 period so
it's going to end up with F of 0 period
and and it's not going to detect that
and then it's going to go into this
underflow case and so you know now is my
chance to figure out where did this
message come from what function did it
even come from the you know if you have
you know 10 different calls to a given
function it may be difficult to figure
out the the stack trace there and so
this is a stack trace exactly when you
want it when the message is being issued
and and this is something that you know
we think is going to make everyone's
lives a lot easier so and and so that is
that is about the end of my talk I just
wanted to to highlight a few other
people in my group who are giving talks
so and one of the big ones at
three-thirty today rober gaez go field
is going to be talking about well the
talk is called mobile CDF deployment but
it's really it's really CDF player on
iOS which is a thing I'm Rob's right on
his iPad I'm running on my iPad if you
want to see it come up to talk to one of
us I think his build is slightly newer
than mine but but we have something that
works and we're we are working like
crazy to be able to actually get
out the door and so also giving talks
about the Wulfen cloudapp nexus minh
utsu is giving a talk tomorrow on 3d
graphics and then we have the talks on
thursday jason harris is giving a
typesetting workshop and lou d'andrea is
if you've had issues with dynamic
programming and like to understand more
about how to work with dynamic dynamic
module etc you definitely want to go to
lose talk I'm also giving a talk on
Thursday morning about the get stuff if
you're interested in that not really
front end dish but if you're interested
in get you'll definitely kind of that so
thank you very much